- I had the honor of visiting
the White House last week
to interview the First Lady.
It's still sinking in.
After our chat, Dr. Biden
asked me just casual like,
"Oh you wanna go see the oval office?"
And I was like, who says who to that?
No one says no to that.
And it's kind of overwhelming.
See, there we are.
Isn't that so cool (chuckling) so cool.
(audience chuckling)
It's never not going to be cool.
I'm getting it like blown up in my office.
But it's just nice to be in a place
where really important things happen.
And the President was so welcoming.
And what's crazy is Dr.
Biden told the President
that my mama was a teacher.
And he immediately didn't
skip a beat, and he goes,
"Well, let's just call
her, let's call her."
And I was like, what?
And then he asked for her number,
and then I look like
such a horrible daughter,
because no one knows
anyone's number. (chuckling)
You just know "Mom" in your contacts.
So now the aides are running around
trying to track down my
phone with my assistant.
And I'm stressing, 'cause I'm like,
"You really don't have to do it.
"It's so nice."
And I'm literally standing
in the oval office.
The oval office, hmm-mmm,
just having a conversation
with President Biden
and Dr. Jill Biden while they're trying
to get ahold of my mom.
And then I look up and Trisha
shows up with my phone,
and my musical director is with her.
And y'all look like you were freaking out.
- Well, to be honest, I was just starving.
And I asked Trisha if there's a sandwich,
and she said they had them
in your dressing room.
So when they came to get Tricia,
I grabbed your big makeup bag real quick
thinking I'm gettin' a sandwich.
I never got the sandwich, but
I got to meet the President.
And I'll carry your makeup bag any day.
(audience applauding)
(Kelly laughing)
- That was amazing!
I walk up and Jason's
holding a makeup bag,
and it's like...
And it's like, the President's
there, and we're leaving,
and I said, "Oh, President
Biden, this is Trisha."
And then all of a sudden I see Jason.
I was like, why is Jason
holding a makeup bag?
(everyone laughing)
Like, what's happening?
And he just wanted a sandwich.
We didn't get that.
But the President called my
mom the next day, literally.
And my mom answered the phone.
She was like, "Hello"
And he was like, "Hi, I'm Joe Biden."
(laughing) And I was
like, "What did you say?"
Anyway, so we have her dialed in.
My mom is actually dialed in right now.
So what's up, Mom?
- Sweetheart.
- [Kelly] Hi!
(audience applauding)
I know that we've gone over this.
And it was really funny,
'cause I couldn't recall.
Everybody kept asking me
what we talked about in the Oval office.
And I couldn't remember a dang thing.
And I remember asking you what happened.
Can you tell everybody else?
- Well, first of all,
I almost didn't answer the
phone, because you know
I don't answer the phone
if I don't know the number.
And sure enough, when I
answered the phone, he said,
"Hi, this is John Joe Biden."
And I thought, "What?"
(Kelly and audience laughing)
I mean, I hate to use
the word surreal, but,
you know he didn't say
President Joe Biden,
he just said, "This is Joe Biden."
And I said, "Oh, hi, how are you?"
He says, "I'm fine."
And then we proceeded to talk about you,
and how much that he
and his wife love you.
- Go on.
(audience chuckling)
- And they are...
They do, they think you are very special.
- I'm just kidding.
- And I said, "Yes, I know
that, she's very special."
And I got to talk to Dr. Jill Biden.
We talked about both being teachers.
She's the oldest of five girls,
and I'm the oldest of four girls.
And she talked about, you know, her,
you know, her sisters and growing up.
I mean, it was just like
talking to a neighbor.
And it was...
They just seem like, you
know, everyday people.
And I thought it was very kind of them,
to call me when they didn't have to.
- Well, I miss you.
(audience applauding)
And I was so excited to get to call you.
I called you from the White
House, it's pretty cool,
I'm just saying.
- That is.
I will have to think about
this in the future though,
I mean, before I should
have thought about this,
before I agreed to do it,
because I haven't had makeup
on now for months and months.
- You're beautiful!!
- So I went in there,
and I looked at my makeup drawer,
and I thought, where do I start?
I don't remember.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Welcome to COVID times. (chuckling)
- So I thought, "Ah..."
- You look beautiful.
- So I apologize to everybody,
but this what it looks like
when you haven't had makeup on it a while.
And you forget what goes where, and...
- Ma'am, that is what it looks
like when you are beautiful,
and you own it (snapping fingers)
like Diane Von Furstenberg.
We're gonna to talk about
that book later this show.
I love you so much.
(audience applauding)
I do think you look beautiful
and I can't wait to see you.
- Love you!
- All right, love you, bye!